hello and welcome to the Helmsley
postdoctoral Teaching scholars capstone
symposium my name is Beth Luoma and it
has been my privilege to serve as the
director of the Helmsley program for the
past almost three years before I go any
further I would like to take the
opportunity to thank some very important
people who have made today's event
possible we obviously have the hard work
of our for Helmsley scholars and you'll
have the chance to hear from each of
them today the program would not have
been possible without our CTL executive
director and principal investigator of
the Helmsley grant Jenny Frederick who
together with our program officers at
the Helmsley Charitable Trust and many
faculty and administrators at the
University of Bridgeport and Housatonic
Community College had the foresight and
vision to design this remarkable program
and frankly to give us all jobs our
program has also benefited from the
insights of expert evaluators including
jan jane man Weiler and glenn davenport
as well as to many faculty staff and
administrators to name at yale ub and
hcc we are grateful to all of you for
the ways you have supported the growth
of these talented postdocs and thrilled
that many of you could be with us here
today i would also like to thank jenny
Ashley who's still hiding out in the
hall there and Patrick O'Brien also
there they are STEM education
administrative assistant and CTL
communications officers who both work
diligently to make sure that today's
event was well organized and well
advertised we would also like to thank
the CTL broadcast team who is recording
our event so it'll be available to our
colleagues who could not attend today
you were certainly about to witness the
results of a team effort we have an
exciting program planned for you today
right now we're in the middle of our
welcome and introduction after I provide
a bit of context about a program you get
the chance to hear from each of our four
current homes we post doctoral scholars
so we'll hear from claudia de grande
sitting at the same table building
communities of students and faculty will
hear from marco Bonett matisse tenfold
increase in attendance of calculus
tutoring sessions facilitating
collaboration and enhancing learning at
UB we'll hear from Sivan Carl inclusive
teaching practices and a classroom
community and beyond and last but
certainly not least we'll hear from
brett Smith
karte days improving preparation for
calculus through gaming and lastly we'll
have closing by Jenny Frederic before we
launch you into our celebratory
reception outside as I mentioned earlier
we are celebrating the culmination of a
three-year program I feel privileged to
have work with not four but a total of
six Helmsley scholars many of you may
also know Scioscia Kreuzberg who was
part of the Helmsley program for the
2015 to 2016 year before securing a
faculty position at Northwestern
University Lake Bookman was also a
Helmsley scholar from 2015 to 2017
working closely with Yale's math
department and establishing our
partnership with the University of
Bridgeport before accepting a position
and Industry to provide some context for
the impact of our work that our homes
the scholars are going to share today I
would like to give some background on
what they've been up to for the past
three years our program was initially
conceived to give recent PhDs and
physics or math who were interested in
teaching focused careers the opportunity
to acquire significant teaching training
and mentorship and so year one was
focused on training they attended summer
Institute's on scientific teaching which
is a national faculty development
program that we run here out of Yale all
right I think we are officially back so
pop quiz what was I talking about we
were talking about the postdocs and all
the incredible things that they've done
over the past three years and so near
one was devoted to training so the
academic year 2015 to 2016 they attended
a Summer Institute on scientific
teaching and they taught introductory
stem courses here at Yale in year two
they really emerged as leaders so they
facilitated our summer Institute's and
scientific teaching and they also led
course innovations here as Yale serving
as course coordinators and they also
began to establish relationships with
our faculty at Housatonic and at UB
through course observations and a number
of meetings and then lastly in year
three this is the year we're currently
and this has really been our extension
phase and so they again emerged as
leaders within our summer Institute's
community serving as facilitators and
they've been teaching our introductory
stem courses at our partner institutions
and I can say from observing every one
of them every semester that's been a
true privilege to watch their evolution
as educators I have too many things
going on
there we go okay great so on a snapshot
for you what is our program been like by
the numbers a few fun facts to throw out
to the room so we have trained six
helmsley postdoctoral Teaching scholars
they have facilitated seven summer
Institute's on scientific teaching they
have taught sixteen unique stem courses
they have organized and led 21 stem
education seminars and as we watch them
depart I'm putting a little asterisks
here to remind myself that we'll be
looking to all of you for ideas for our
seminar series so during the reception
there is a suggestion box out there and
if the true incentive of your
intellectual contribution isn't enough
we're going to do a random drawing for a
CTL moleskin so please make sure you put
in your ideas into that box another
thing I want to go back here to mention
to with our summer Institute's is we've
really been privileged to have faculty
teams from both Housatonic and you be
attending those Institute's as well our
postdocs have attended 23 disciplinary
and education conferences they've taught
33 individual course sections and taken
together they've taught over 1,300
unique undergraduate students so I'd say
that they've done a lot over the past
few years I think what will become
obvious today is that the influence of
our postdocs by no means stopped at
their classroom walls the successes of
our Helmsley scholars are the result of
their talents and hard work but also the
support of so many here in this room
today and so this symposium and the
reception that will follow is that once
a celebration of our homes Lee scholars
and a display of gratitude to all of you
so let's begin Claudia will be our first
presenter each of our homes Lee scholars
will present for about 15 minutes and
then we'll allow up to five minutes for
question following each presentation so
without further ado Claudia
hello everyone get familiar with this
spot so it's been really challenging to
only have 15 minutes to summarize three
years of teaching both are Jelena
Housatonic Community College so I tried
to look for some common common trend or
common object actually so what I found
is a table a table has been sort of
emblematic of my growth and the projects
that are being involved with so I'm
gonna talk about tables today does
therefore domain tables have been
involved with samurai Yale and samurai
has atonic Community College I want to
start by talking to talk about the Yale
classroom the teal classroom those
tables are circular tables is right then
in Hill House Street and this is where
how the till classroom looked like when
I started as a teaching assistant very
crowded students still had their laptop
opens that doesn't happen anymore it was
very intimidating but over the years I
got very comfortable in that environment
and what I want to tell you about is a
story about the first year when we
taught a class a class year at Yale I
think
sorry I just have to do one little thing
so we basically did an experiment we
offer students the option to either take
our physics introductory classes for
pre-med and biology majors either in
this classroom that's an overview of the
class or they could have chosen to take
exactly the exact same classroom in a
very nice traditional lecture hall after
he'll in the chemistry department so the
two classes were the two sections were
run in parallel at the same time you
were two instructors myself and Simon
Moultrie and then myself and Ron Aramis
and we were developing the material
together so the classroom we were exact
the class was exactly the same same
homeworks same same assignment
the only variable was the environment
student could choose one versus the
other classroom and I have to say that
the way we encourage group work and
collaboration was exactly the same it
was not more suitable for one classroom
versus the other one so the question
that we asked was does the classroom
make a difference how is the experience
of students in around a table or sitting
just in a row so I gathered a data from
the final grade of students in this
class so those are the histogram of the
final grade of on the left is the teal
classroom on the right the lecture hall
and if we look at the average grade what
happened is it's the first semester
students in the lecture hall did almost
significantly better the students in the
teal classroom well we thought back then
is that there is some sort of self
selection maybe that good students
motivated students are somewhat
skeptical of this new classroom with
tables we don't know what a dialect what
that is let's stick with the traditional
classroom that's somewhat confirmed by a
pre/post test that we ran for the class
while you look for pre with pre post
test is the average gain and average
gain was the same for the two classroom
but students in the lecture hall had a
significantly significantly higher
pretest what is interesting to us then
is what happened in the spring semester
so most of the students are required to
take two semesters of the class so they
take the first and then the second
semester so what happened in the spring
semester the opposite happened
I have to say that most of the student
we're in the same classroom they didn't
release which some of them switched but
that was in both directions so I kind of
make sure that wasn't a significant
shift and so what happened is that now
students in the teal classroom litter
our classroom with the tables performs
significantly better than the students
in the lecture hall more precisely to
look at this data what I did I filter
sort of for what I call the overlap
students I mean the students that were
actually both in this fall in the spring
some student might take the class the
following year they came back from a
near abroad or something so I only took
the students that were actually in the
classroom both semesters so if you look
at this more carefully I analyze this
dividing these in three categories so
basically based on their grade in the
fall semester I divided the students in
high-performing media performing and low
performing so this is an a this is a
minus B plus and then this B in mine and
less than that and I looked how the
performance was followed in the spring
semester so this was very interesting so
what happened is that medium and high
performing students had a comparable
performance no matter in which classroom
they were but low performing students
performed significantly better only in
the teal classroom of course this is
just data there's so much more I can add
as an experience that annexes as a
teacher teaching in the to classroom and
experiencing the energy and all the
stories that can happen in a classroom
but I'm gonna stop here just to kind of
move forward and just say since that is
maybe a teal table effect
I didn't clarify that this students
choose to sit at the table and that year
they sat with the same people for the
entire semester so my suggestion is that
is a filling of a community that it did
take over two semester to be developed
that I think will make a difference if
you're sitting in at a table or if
you're sitting in a classroom I would
say a student is not very motivated my
fall behind if you can sit alone in a
big large lecture hall well if you have
a classroom where you sitting on with
meet youryour friends you might feel
like more motivated to to work harder
but let me just now guess and show you
what our students comments so I'll leave
you a few seconds if you can read
through those
this is from the anonymous survey day we
do every semester I just want to
highlight few words that are significant
there is an accessibility that the
instructor they clearly make a
difference and I'm sorry you're sitting
in a row but I would like to walk around
to show you how you can access an
instructor if you have tables and you
work around isn't any more centrality
but the center is at the table and
students can really connect with you
much better there is clearly a feeling
of a more personalized and collaborative
collaborative environment because you
sit with friends at the table so this is
about student in the lecture there is
much more to happen at the tables
outside the lectures and so what I want
to talk about next is study hall so
study hall is a very simple thing but it
turned out to be one of the most
successful tools of our classroom and it
brought it to Elsa tonic has been used
in physics a lot and it's very simple
but it's great so let me sell study hall
to you so did you ever study holding a
nutshell is you're gonna hold office
hours in a just more inclusive way most
of us have offices upon the Undong
signed seal is a very dark small offices
and student come up they're all concern
to ask a question to you forget about
that now you come down the hill you go
to a place that is convenient for a
student at the time that is convenient
for the students so that's what study
hall is so there are two or three times
a week two or three hours where we meet
in the teal classroom and the main point
is that we sit at the table with the
students so that's where somewhat the
change happens this again you're not
instructor anymore you're sitting with
them and so besides of course helping
them with the homework you get to talk
about so many other things I get to know
about their extracurricular activities
they reach each other about things that
happen on campus that they wouldn't find
out otherwise so it's really a way to
build a community and I also want to
show you some fun pictures of course
social events that we had they build
some stuff at the beginning of the
semester we have some group formation
and I also have to say that a study hold
there are instructors which is
fundamental but they're also teaching a
system peer tutors those are
undergraduate student they took the
class before so the students can come
and they can decide to talk to me but
they don't
have to actually they also just come and
talk to each other by creating the space
you facilitate group formation and the
fact that they make friends with each
other let me show you again some quotes
so what we like to ask the students in
our class is imagine you could write a
short paragraph for next year students
what would you advise to them to learn
and have the best experience in the
class so I sort of coded all the
responses from this survey and the main
idea that come out are more more than
half of them say you should attend study
hall but in general the good things that
they say is that a value collaboration
they are comfort of a skin questions and
they also say you should get to know
your professors which is pretty nice and
I would say most of them combined are
more than a couple of those let me show
you again some comments from this survey
those quotes sort of really speak to the
philosophy that we have behind the class
which is about growth and it's okay to
be wrong as long as you ask for help the
help is there for you so statical is
exactly the place where it's there isn't
there is never wrong a growing question
to be asked and to not be afraid and
always ask for help we also have always
asked these five questions over the fire
of we asked for five questions of the
past four semester and I average the
results that I'm going to show you to
you to sort of capture what's the
atmosphere the students perceived in
this class so we asked them how did you
find the atmosphere and Simon came up
with this a love-in is the top two
hostile on the other side so this is
what's the average most of them finding
welcoming we also ask them if they feel
supported by both their instructor and
the classmates so on the Left we have
instructors and on the right we have
classmates I found interesting and this
is part also the being human in stem
that I might be able to talk about the
fact that students feel more supported
by the instructor than their classmates
so it's a good point for reflections
another important point is ask them how
the class compared to other stem classes
on the last and known stem classes that
I yield there is this well-known thing
that stem classes are not as becoming as
known stem classes so this is pretty
nice to see that half of them think that
it's either about the same or better
than announced and class and in general
is definitely a much better experience
that the other large ten classes that
they're used to I want to emphasize that
all these results of these five plus
that I showed you I looked if there is
any difference among group racial groups
and there isn't so this is the response
has been humongous they ever say
consistent with all the students in the
class a few more comments again about
the class they talk about community
friendliness and accessibility and one
thing that we really like is that they
say they don't feel like they're
competing with each other this is also
because we don't grade on a curve but
that's I guess another story so this has
been my experience with physics 117 117
a 71 year Yale and I want to talk about
what happened when now last fall I
started up
Tony Community College it's been really
interesting to meet new students I can
come up with few things to summarize how
students at a community college are
different their ego is not as big as the
ego VL students they have to be
encouraged
I actually I have to cheer for them I
have to tell them you have to submit the
homework that's good for you they don't
have they have a life they work their
study habits are not as developed by
Yale students because studying is not
their priority they're not so used to
working groups and so the first semester
has been quite challenging because I had
to substitute to them and get to know
them and also to my teaching style I was
used to in a different environment so
it's been I wouldn't say rough but it's
been bumpy but I realized when I was
preparing this presentation that one of
the reason maybe why wasn't so easy is
because I was missing a table so
isotonic in the fall semester I was
running study hall and the classroom and
everything as I was doing here but we
didn't really have a teal classroom
there the cool news is that this
semester Housatonic has been going
through a renovation of both buildings
and there are two wonderful rooms they
really made a difference so on the right
is the new tutoring center and that's
the table where I hold study hall and on
the left is one I'd like to call a mini
teal I love the fact that the chairs are
colored and I have to say it in January
when I came in those tables were all in
a line and I rushed there to change them
and put them like that and you can
confirm that they remain like that since
then
so what we do right now after every
lecture we go during with working groups
and we have handout and students working
group and this has really made a
difference as I like to say my students
this semester only 15 they're loving in
their lovable I like the class it's been
wonderful I asked them the same
questions that I asked 2zl students and
you see the loving it's much higher
there are only 14 of them but they are
all very engaged I think somebody's just
always want to say that it's their
environment is hostile whatever maybe
just click the Run button but I made
sure at least I was a little concerned
about that one but a hundred percent
said they feel supported by the
instructors so that hostility might come
from something else I don't know so
so that's been my experience it feels if
I felt so short I felt like I just got
used to it and it's ending unfortunately
I want to end with one more table right
now just outside the library there is
wlh this room is right there where Simon
had to leave because right now Savannah
and I otherwise will be teaching the
being human in stem course it's at its
second implementation and this is a
course that has been developed a mais
college of years ago and then we
imported here Yale briefly what is this
class is a collaboration between faculty
and students and the most emblematic way
we sit at the table with the students so
imagine 10 or 12 students and four or
five faculty in stem we all sit around
this table and here are some comments
from the students of this class of the
class this year how they feel about the
fact that we sit at the table with them
so this class is a completely new story
and I won't have time to go through it I
just want to show you some of the
successive of last year this class was
the first class that ran a workshop for
faculty where students told faculty in
stem what they should do to make their
classes more inclusive is becoming a
network with people are immersed and if
you wanna more and learn more about it
this is a great way for me to advertise
you we have a summit coming up in three
weeks here at Yale on a Sunday because
it's also reading a reading period so if
you want to hear more about this class
consider joining us today so I'm going
to end here and let you reflect on
tables and take questions yes
oh you want me to tell their I had a
very successful job search and I'm
moving to Salt Lake City as its called
professor of educational practice so
I'll be teaching but we also have time
to be involved with exactly what I've
been doing here it feels like a natural
extension of this fellowship because
I'll be involved with projects in STEM
education and the divide in part the
environment is so has been so wonderful
so I'm very excited thank you yes
so it's a good question because actually
turns out that two years ago a Yale we
change the time and I ended up having
only 13 students in the teal classroom
so there was this huge classroom empty
and only two tables and so that's a
little awkward sometimes when you ask
them let's talk to each other the
classroom is kind of very quiet but now
that I see a house atonic I only have 15
students what has been challenging is to
ask them to mix with each other but I'll
be using like little tricks like what's
your favorite food or where you were
born to make them with each other so I
think I'm getting better is all about
creating I think the the relationship
with them and then even if it's a small
class it works well yeah so it's been
more kind of practicing with different
sizes you always treat one person with
hostility but when you have this more
communitarian approach if somebody is a
bit of an outlier does that ever affect
how things go for you
did you notice yeah I do have those
cases regularly have to say people that
really like to work on their own I would
say I let them be because I don't feel
like I should force them to be the
friend and one day I feel like I dude I
do tell them that working with other
people is part of anybody's career and
so I asked them to move which we move
around and talk to other people I try to
connect with those people I tried to
connect more one-on-one to make sure
that I I know they're a little different
but I'm ok with that
so I would say for small class that
works well for a bigger class is more
work but yeah mm-hmm Frank
thank you yes I forgot one thing that is
great about Housatonic so I have a study
hall on Monday afternoon because on
Tuesday we have a quiz so I always had a
study hall before something important so
they come to prepare it turns out that I
has a tonic Monday afternoon is way too
early for them to worry about a quiz
which is on Tuesday but the great thing
is there half of them I would say 6 or 7
students do show up regularly just to
hang out so they just come they sit
there they work on the homework do the
same night they tell me about other
classes we talk about other things some
of them asked me about physics so the
others by sort of like you know just
being there they heard they learn
something but is religions just come to
show up and be with each other so it's
interesting I think yell students come
to study all with a list of questions
they're like helping with this and these
and that and so it's very different but
they're very appreciated appreciating
[Music]
yeah when we do is only six people so we
tend to see that the one or two tables a
study hold at that time yeah it's a
small class so now we all sit at the
same table yeah yeah thank you for the
questions hello everyone
can you guys hear me on the back or
should I use the microphone cool
thanks so much everyone for coming
I'm going to share with you my
experiences this past year as a Hemsley
postdoctoral scholar and if I was to
summarize my experience in the last year
it would be fun and extremely creative
I've been given have been granted an
amount of freedom you have no idea and
as I was debating what is it that I
wanted to share with you guys a
recurring theme that kept on popping up
was the impact which I think Beth has
already alluded to and I wanted it to
share with you guys the project that
have been involved that has the largest
had the largest impact but then soon I
realized that I was serving as a vehicle
for the CTL to have an impact outside of
the boundaries on Yale so I want you to
continue I invite you to continue to
remind yourself as I present that I am
just sharing with you something of what
in my opinion has a great impact outside
of the Yale boundaries both inside and
outside I part I want to have also been
part of the inside impact but this is
outside of it and to begin I want to
begin for with the element that I think
has the largest importance in my opinion
not only in this project but in life in
general and that is people and first I
want to express my immense gratitude to
Jennifer
frederik for the list of issues that i
am not even going to go into it except
to say that it is a long list I am
extremely grateful I am also forever in
depth to Beth for having email me and
suggested to apply for this particular
position a speaking of impact I would
have been another statistic I seduced
into industry who and I'm very
passionate about education so it would
have been just another dot in the in the
mountain amount of people that live at
toward the industry and finally the ease
in which I have been able to navigate
the UB landscape would not have been
possible without the mentoring and
guidance of Rann McCulloch who is a
great person that also happens to be the
math share at UB I'm saddened that he
wasn't able to join us today he's in a
conference in Florida so what I want to
do next is provide you a bird's-eye view
of my presentation first I want to share
the context of this tutoring project
because I've done teaching and I want to
make sure that I share that with you
then briefly I'm going to explore what
this student project has been and at the
end give you a sense of where we might
go after this year so to begin with a
couple of milestones have had at UB is
my classes have been excellent have had
excellent reviews from the students
perspective my calculus 3 class had a
3.7 out of 4 and my differential
equations class at 3.6 out of 4 these
are University students evaluations
anonymous not disheartened given by
provided by me and this only says that
they like the way I teach I hope that it
translates in into a student learning I
stood in two learning gains I'm not
going to speculate I hope it does I've
also come to
as all of the postdocs have to the STEM
education seminars and finally I've
developed in class mindfulness practices
that had it not been for the tutoring
project which I want to highlight today
I would have spent the 10 minutes
talking about this however I want to
share a little bit of what that entails
so this mindfulness exercises are an
outgrowth of my quizzes which are every
day and I've been playing with them for
the last seven years and what I believe
my current hypothesis in terms of what
this mindfulness practices do is and I
think it's a little bit of what claudia
was referring to is they accelerate the
rate at which the build of trust is
happens I don't I don't think
mindfulness exercise is built Ross I
think people build trust but just like
it was observe in Claudia's talk it took
maybe I don't know I'm gonna speculate a
year for to see the effect of the trust
build in the till classroom I speculate
that this exercises could accelerate
that process so let me tell you a little
bit of what I have observed in my
classroom and what I use as indirect
evidence that this is the case and what
I am showing I'm going to show you next
are three quotes from three students
last semester this were unsolicited
responses and all I am going to say is
that they were read in it then it'll be
a email or by a paper so I'm gonna give
you a couple seconds to read them please
let me know if you guys on the back
cannot see them
so what I want to comment is I want to
direct your attention to the last two
questions which were written in the blue
books within the time of the final exam
and this is totally consistent with the
way my mindfulness exercise are
implemented after the quizzes within the
class where we follow a thing per share
activity then I asked my students to
reflect on their own learning and then
they write down these things I was going
to do it but usually what I do is I
create a PDF you know and I give at this
PDF of the order of their progress prior
to the exam so that they can see you
know what's working what is not working
I wasn't going to discuss the next two
slides but I realized I had more time so
I squeezed them in this are responses
from this year where before they even
knew anything about me which is in blue
I asked them whether they thought I
cared about their learning this is
before any mindfulness exercises were
implemented in the classroom and the one
on red is what happens after one
particularly important one that I found
extremely effective at I think it's like
lubricating the ways in which we connect
to our students or the ways in which I
have connected to my students I also
asked them whether they trust my
teaching style as I said it has bidding
it has been very creative and it's been
very creative so the thing is that do
they think that this works or they might
some interesting guy and they seem to
trust what I've done in the classroom at
least according to this this is one
survey that I asked them so keep that in
mind so that's as far as the context
this concern of dontation a played with
Titian in the classroom and now I want
to shift my attention to what I really
want to discuss which is the tutoring
and the ways in which
I've tried to improve children at juvie
and from for that I'm going to kind of
like tell ground you through the
chronology of it last semester before my
appointment began I read where Lake left
off we who is the postdoc that left and
I luckily was able to fill in his shoes
and he had a line that said to her and
that was it
and I wasn't going to reinvent the wheel
so I went to the tutoring center
volunteer my time for a month
Wednesday is there just help out
understand the audience and see where
can I contribute to the tutoring center
so I go there and now what I want to do
I didn't say it once again the impact of
the CTL is here
what I did is then I was offered to hire
the tutors implement an interview
process I suggested that we meet
bi-weekly it was optional last semester
and finally I implemented a system of
feedback the last three of them are
directly from the playbook of the CTL
where we had a coordinator such as Beth
who implemented the interviews she hired
me as a coordinator one year we met
twice a week and we definitely
implemented feedback during that time
but then what we observed having
implemented this system of feedback was
that students weren't coming for
calculus so I go to Ryan and I said is
you know does this make sense he says no
we should be having more attendance into
this meeting so now we have a North Star
that we can follow as a group and we
were ambitious we said we're aiming for
a tenfold increase in tutoring sessions
attendance which is the why the title
and I was lucky enough that in the
cohort that we were there last semester
Debbie was there and Debbie is with us
today if I'm to be honest she's done
more work in the to make this project
work
I have and she should be the one who
should be presenting here so please
please please engage her at the end if
you're curious about this tutors
perspective however in brief she has
facilitated the tutored faculty
interaction
she has leading coordinate the bi-weekly
meetings this semester I'm thinking
sustainability I did it last semester I
want to pass the baton unto her get her
to experience professional development
she is right now mentoring new tutors
that will take on her roles next
semester and other many logistical stuff
that I'm not even aware she does but she
does I've also been lucky enough to have
two tutors who have invested heavily one
of them Chris is with us today and they
have collaborated with faculty
facilitated this color this dialogue
advertiser to the limitations but most
importantly they have maintained the
students attendance so something that I
really notice based on focus groups with
students is that they come to the
tutoring sessions they have a negative
experience they go
and Chris and Hamza have done a
fantastic work at retaining those
students to continue to come so we go we
get to work and the outcome so far Chris
created this data for me last night and
we've gone to a five-fold increase up
until yesterday my hope is that we still
have three weeks review sessions finals
coming we might hit our target of a
tenfold increase of also I mean if we
include all the years we have an
infinite fold increase so I'm gonna take
credit for that but if I agree get the
to calculus and all the years we're at
80 percent at 80 fold in Eightfold
increase so these are the outcomes
let me summarize them for you again um
I'm only talking about the tutoring but
there's more that I did at UB we've
increased at 10
in calculus tutoring sessions we have
facilitated de tried this triad
collaboration which I think strengthens
the community and we in my opinion have
improved undergraduate learning
experience this I'm not I don't think
I'm telling you anything that you might
have not guessed from an effort like
this however there are more intangibles
that I can share with you which are we
have triggered the tutors curiosity and
this is in my opinion the most powerful
effect an impact that we've had on these
students because now they're hungry
they're curious and I'm interested in
capitalizing on that on that potential
we've also strengthened the sense of
community and their cell their self
agency they I want to be respectful but
they were a bit scattered now they were
building cohesion and they did studying
to demonstrate some initiative which i
think is an intangible yet very powerful
so i'm giving you numbers because we're
driven by numbers but I think these two
are really the effects that I'm more
impressed by or more passionate about if
you will so where do we go I was lucky
enough to a position opened up I applied
and I was able I'm going to be able to
remain at UB for another year so what do
we do with all these potential I am
interested in implementing and I'm
dreaming I'm telling you my dreams I'm
interested in implementing a math bridge
program that is led by tutors I'm
interested in mentoring them in the
course design aspect of it let them do
all the work just make sure that it is
done well in having them implement the
bridge program themselves again like I'm
interested in a lot of intangibles here
professional development being one of
them and I think this serves that
purpose going back to the stem education
seminars this is more my personal goal
is I would like to maintain this SME
education seminar series but
would like to contribute now as a role
of UB member so having more ownership in
terms of UB as an institution for this
similar series but also try to get a
stakeholders from neighboring
institutions so that we can build in
this little momentum I've been I've
helped Claudia with her seminar last
semester and I did one a couple a week
ago and I think that we're starting to
get some momentum going there and I will
like to keep that going if possible
finally I would like to involve
undergraduate students in my research my
research is in theoretical nuclear
physics and I'll be curious to get some
of them exposed to these research
techniques so that's all thank you any
questions can you tell us a little about
the makeup of your tutors at UB and
their availability when just said the
make they are mostly undergraduates
debbie is the graduate student good
other students are given 24 hours it
usually is two of them and
undergraduates get 70 hours some of them
are embedded tutors in algebra I took
the calculus ones that those are the
ones that I took ownership of they are
for one of them has 7 hours the other
one's got have 4 there the idea is that
now that I bet I have a better handle on
who they are is to Chapel those hours
around so that tutors like Chris get
more hours next semester yeah and they
yeah they amount to as I said for
calculus tutors in a total of around 7
to 8 tutors
/ you know but they some of them do
algebra and I'm not as familiar with
what they do when they go into embedded
to the embedded classes so putting this
together what are the things that were
sort of strange or things that students
might be skeptical of so what is it that
I did that might have taken a little
with a little bit suspicious is that the
question I mean the mindfulness right
I'd ring a dong and I ask them to be
silent for a minute and and it takes
them a little bit to to get comfortable
with that silence so some of them start
writing immediately some of them start
knocking on things and so the first
three trials are failed trials because
I'm trying to correct for this but
toward the end they embrace it it's it's
is like the only way that I can explain
it is it is a very visceral low-level
way of engagement that I cannot
articulate how it works
I can only sense it be present and play
with it
so let me let me explain let me explain
the quiz right so they come into the
class at 1:30 sharp there's a quiz in
front of them and they sit there by
themselves for six minutes answer it
I collected once I well I am entering
the results they are engaging in
discussion groups and so on then I
collect those I showed them the
Instagram of the first of mission and I
tell them should I discuss any of the
answers sometimes they say third
sometimes I said all of them so I go
through that thing per share process and
then at the end what I ask them is to
remain silent for a minute try to
observe the reactions in terms of the
quiz and I guide them by telling them
what was my goal what how did they feel
what were the study methods that might
have worked
what were their study methods that
didn't work for one minute they are
thinking about this and then the second
minute I let them write and as I said in
the beginning it's uncomfortable they
don't know what to tell me it's personal
in the beginning it's a little bit
personal and with guidance say this
again so they write it they give it to
me I grade them and then I read it and
in the beginning is very personal it's
all about me Oh children ask good
questions I don't understand this thing
you're two we're and then I tell them I
tell them I tell them look guys like I
get it please express yourself however
you want but can can I invite you to
explore your learning can I ask you to
reflect on your learning not so much and
whether you like this whole thing but
you're learning and please complain
about me with the anonymous feedback
form which is also there for them and
then it is loosely becomes amid a
cognition exercise for them so that is
one example I have music in the
beginning of the class I plays blues and
they enter and they don't know what to
do with that so those are the creative
things that in the beginning they are
they are client trying to make sense of
me but for whatever reason they start to
trust me and like my mental picture is
we're going to build this much trust one
person a and person B are going to build
this much trust the question is what is
the half life that it takes to get from
here to there and this whole exercises
accelerate the process shorten the half
life of that process what is it that I'm
going with this so they're gonna trust
me however much they're going to trust
me
this only facilitates the built of that
trust and I'm like I'm eccentric so in
my presentation of the car and and and
it takes a little bit to adjust Marco
for the Summer Bridge Program that
you're dreaming about what is that as
far as is it face to face is it
expensive do you have funding for it so
so I found out about the funding issue
last week I think the funding I'm
starting to feel more optimistic about
it now it's more the course design
aspect of it that we're running short so
I'm thinking I want to make sure that
that we do it well because is it
sensitive it if it's not well I'm afraid
there won't be a second chance so for
the second year my hope is that someone
like Chris and other tutors who have
expressed a lot of interest in it
they've matured they will mature in
their teaching abilities and will have
more time to plan it out well it'll
ambition a five-week no children that
because I don't think three weeks is
enough to have any learning gains I'm
interested in learning games not so much
acclamation to the University so that's
my goal my goal is to develop the
algebra and their study habits I'm
teaching 200-level classes and I'm as
claudia has already mentioned I'm
working on their study habits my goal is
to to work on the on develops those in
the bridge program so that we can do
more fun stuff in the classroom
are we good on time I feel you know like
that I think active learning has really
spoiled me and made me really nervous
like whenever I hear when I whenever
there's a crowd that is just willing
they're just sitting there to listen to
me that I get a little bit nervous now
because I always engage thick so I'm
gonna try to make this an inter
interactive talk a little bit if that's
okay just because because I have been
this program has given me an opportunity
to be an interactive teacher and I want
to sort of implement this here as well
does that okay with everybody can I hear
yes or no okay thank you very much okay
all right so just to give you my
background I joined the post doctorate
program in 2016
first year 2016-2017 I taught at Yale
and then second year 2017 to present I'm
teaching at the University of Bridgeport
so so I'm teaching introductory physics
at both these institutions so I'm just
gonna get started with the culture of
the classroom and so I think you know
there are some parallels that I've been
able to gather teaching and very having
this very interesting experience
teaching at different institutions at
here as well as the University of
Bridgeport and I I can I will try to
synthesize some of the things that I've
learned teaching at these different
institution and see if there are some
parallels and some of the things that
have worked well in different
institutions also have a conversation
about things that I could do better as
well
I feel the thing that I've learned is
every classroom maybe at Yale
or University of Bridgeport anywhere as
a result of various complex interaction
I you know like I feel like going into a
classroom thinking that oh I'm an
experienced teacher and I'm trying to
implement certain things and every time
I thought that I had it every time I
thought that I knew what to do I feel
like it's been challenged you know like
every classroom is different every
institution is different and there are
interesting dynamic that plays out
somehow in the classroom and so maybe
I'll have a little bit of conversation
about this and there's and and I think
being a teacher made P in physics or in
humanities or any discipline I think
it's very important to realize that
there's a range of ideas that are
represented in the classroom
and different students who come to our
classrooms have different reasons where
they come to a classroom and if we don't
interact with them if you don't talk to
them then there's no way we can actually
know what their motivations are and what
their interests are and how can we peer
how can we understand their motivation
is some of the things that I've been
thinking about in the last couple of
years and only way that we can know
about our students is by being connected
with them and how can we connect with
them and not just being connected with
students the faculty and students being
connected to each other but allowing an
environment where students can connect
with each other and form that community
that some of my other colleagues have
already talked about so I'm just gonna
start off with a group discussion you
know some of us are teachers here and
some of us are interested in teaching so
let's just have a conversation about
what are the few things that you have
tried or would like to try to make your
classroom inclusive can we have a group
discussion maybe like find a partner
next to you and have a conversation I
know you guys are ready to talk to each
other so get to know each other and so
[Music]
yeah yeah yeah unconscious yeah yeah
yeah okay
okay I'm sorry I'm sorry to interrupt
I'm sorry to interrupt okay so can I can
I have everybody's attention back again
okay can I get you know like part of the
reason I do this part of the reason now
I've been teaching in this sort of mode
like if I just talk I get so nervous I
don't know if you guys have this like
you know like people who have
implemented
you know interactive teaching I just
cannot not make other people talk in my
classroom because I do it for myself
more then I mean of course I do it for
the students as well but I do it for
myself so but can I hear some some
strategies maybe from somewhere from the
back can you guys you know like tell me
what the strategies that you have used
or think are useful anybody I know you
guys were talking okay right at the back
like body language in a classroom what's
her name again
okay we're out of pasta Michelle I just
wanted to give a glimpse of my classroom
this is how you know like if I were to
call it somebody I just want to like you
know if I call somebody I ask them -
I've asked all the students to give a
round applause so I just it just creates
a sort of subtle thing but it's a
community that is developed through you
know like supporting each other and
that's I think that's really important
Thank You Michelle okay I will move
forward so some of the things that I
have implemented is an active classroom
which is vital to creating that sort of
community and and and a community
between people who are teaching but as
well as between students getting to know
students outside of physics you know
like outside just beyond their names is
absolutely important to make sure that
there's that trust between students and
faculty
and then also reinforcing the love of
learning right so I will talk about
these three things in the next few
slides that I have so here's the teal
classroom so I want to say this is the
talk about tables this is not exactly
the talk well this is partly the talk
about tables but I didn't like cloudy I
talked a lot about the teal classroom so
I like there's a lot of things that
Claudia and also Marco has talked about
that overlaps with my own experience as
well and so certainly like my experience
in teal has been extremely positive
I encourage active learning group
projects and team-based problem-solving
in this environment and so you know like
I think somebody already asked how
difficult it is when there's a serengeti
of this room you know like it's far away
and but but I feel like one thing that
I've realized about teal classroom is
even though there are a large number of
students as well as a smaller number of
students this sort of collaborative you
know table like environment works
extremely well for creating that
community so this was my experience at
Yale and then I went to University of
Bridgeport and so so what did i do at
University of Bridgeport so there's an
active learning so I wanted to reinforce
the same experience that I had here and
I wanted to take it to the University of
Bridgeport so University bridge but does
not have the teal or
so-called TL classroom but I don't think
it's necessary that's the most important
thing that I wanted to point out the
great thing that happened when I went to
the University of issue that was that I
realized that these these these tables
and desks that are moveable right so
like I see like some of the students are
nodding very happily and so like all we
had to do was to move these deaths
around and that's all we had to do
because there's students the size of the
students that the number of students
that I taught at Bridgeport the class
number were about 30 or so and so you
know like so I emulated the same model
they're movable desks and chairs and I
created this sort of community where
students are actually talking to each
other much like in the teal setting it's
essentially the same idea without the
acronym so and it's and and and and I
feel the effect is the same I think much
like Claudia alluded I think these kind
of environments where our students are
working in groups it's particularly
beneficial for students who are
underrepresented in science students who
have low confidence and in in their
ability to learn physics and I think you
like anybody who's worked in this sort
of setting and have done it somewhat
well had has this experience so so
that's the first thing that I wanted to
talk about which is active learning the
second thing about the inclusive
teaching strategies and these are by no
means exhaustive that I want to talk
about is we have to be interested I feel
towards students as human beings and so
so these are some of the examples that I
have you know like try to try to be try
to be close to students by attending
some of the events that students would
invite me like so here's a ballet in
general I'm not interested in ballet but
I would go there and hear a but and I
thought okay this is something that i
can't take interest in you know students
can teach you so much is something that
I have learned over this experience
here's here's a play Julius Caesar and
here's my student right there zib and I
didn't know he was so vicious in his
it's acting he there he is being Cassius
Cassius and I didn't I hadn't seen a
better cashius in my life and so and so
like you know like this sort of
connection sorry you have
and certainly biased but you know but
but yeah absolutely biased about this
but but this was an amazing experience
because I can see these students outside
of class and they and and Carly and I
are teaching this class called being
human stem and seeing their humanity
even though they're about to kill poor
Julius Caesar out there is it's quite
refreshing so so that's that's that's
another thing and then you know like
this is certainly like one thing
obviously you know like like everybody
has schedule constrains and you know you
cannot go to plays or you know like or
activities that students but you know
like whenever there's a cafeteria and
there's a student sitting by themselves
if you can offer to like sit by them
it's a small gesture that can make such
a big impact not only with that student
but but the student community at large
and it's something that I've learned
teaching at these institutions certainly
like feedback is another way of
connecting with students um you know
like here's an example a very recent
example of students telling me what they
have not learned well in class and what
are their challenges here's a here's an
email that just came yesterday or was a
day before yesterday where like student
had we were doing electric circuits and
they they thanked me for certain things
that I did well and they also wanted me
to touch on certain topics so if I did
not have these feedbacks I would not
know what their interests are right like
I mean a teaching cannot be a one-way
street we just have to get as much
feedback as possible from students and
so that's another thing that I've
learned from this experience and then
there's a another thing that I wanted to
touch here's a question for you so
they're like three choices so we're
gonna vote with one two and three and so
like are you guys ready are you guys do
you need more time to answer these
questions okay on the count of three it
has to be simultaneous one two three
okay okay let's together it out on one
two three fun okay yeah there should be
no dividing line between fun and physics
I think you know like like how can you
be motivated to learn something that
you're not interested in here's an
example of you know like I wish I'd
taken more videos while I was teaching
there so here's an example of some
serendipitous
moment that happened in a classroom I
was doing this sort of launching every
ring and somebody's watch came about
it's only that they're having fun and I
think you know like this is sort of
emblematic of the classroom that I try
to create and and that sort of motivates
them to learn physics as well
oops sorry so now so I want to stop here
and and can you like talk about can you
like maybe have a discussion about
couple more inclusive strategies maybe
can you can you can you think of a
couple more inclusive strategies and
then I'll show you a couple more and
then I'll and talk okay maybe a couple
more inclusive strategies
I hate - I hate I really hate - I really
hate to cut this short you guys this is
really hard to stop because okay you
know like I really hate to cut this
short I know how much fun it is to talk
to each other you know like there's no
point learning if you cannot share it
with others and this is something that
you have demonstrated in this small in
this small conversation but can we talk
about a couple more teaching strategies
anybody who's pitching to answer it do
somebody yes with regard to group word
what I enjoy doing what my students end
up enjoying doing is I break them up
into teams of four for some reason for
is a magic number and I have them do a
quiz no they set up a blank page they do
their quizzes they work together to put
together the quiz questions and then I
have the group's swap the quizzes so I
use it as not only a learning tool and a
review but it's also good for them to
really understand it at a different
level so it's not that just they're just
answering it they have to actually
formulate the question you have to
formulate the answers and then they have
to explain it to the other group if they
get it wrong so it's kind of a win-win
john-boy chair of the math science
department at Housatonic can you give
her a round of applause again so I'm
gonna end with some teaching strategies
and I know a lot of you are have thought
about it as deeply as I have or more so
exam Corrections are one of the things
that I've learned from cloudy actually
so I am indebted to her for teaching me
about exam Corrections which sort of
lowers the stake and you know it's a
metacognitive a cognitive activity and
you know students like you know you you
you know a lot of times students just
throw their exams after if they don't do
well and they never learn that topic and
our goal is to teach students right and
so use that as an opportunity to have
metacognition and also solidify like
their their understanding especially in
physics and
other science courses they build on one
after the other and so having that exam
correction is amazing we have we have
you know like like making sure that
especially under under under prepared
students are are understanding the
material well incorporating diversity in
the curriculum in general like you know
like I I'm done with putting in pictures
of Einstein and Bohr in in my slides I'm
just done about you know and so that's
another thing I just want to be more
like inclusive in terms of you know like
science as a as an endeavor that can be
done by just about everybody and and
making you know like like giving
different ways of actually making like
you know like like like when you're
teaching circuits for instance you can
like show simulations and their
equations and then a bunch of ways so
that soon can access different people
with different ways of learning and
access access learning access the
material in different ways and then
finally like you know like I think
probably most importantly I didn't know
I don't know how why I have a reason why
I spelled that wrong because I just
added that like sneakily like when I was
sitting there and part of the reason is
me and Brett we're having lunch before
this and student who was in my class
last semester came to me and said can I
give you a hug and I think that's sort
of emblematic of my experience here
really I feel like you know I've learned
and also felt love and warmth of so many
students and I took I took a bunch of
selfies with students but I just thought
of him and I added this picture and so
this sort of sort of this is like so
Francis is the student here and to the
right and left
it was Malaika and Francis gave me a
bear hug just before I came here and so
I just thought that I should include
this picture there so I'll stop here
thank you
[Applause]
any questions yes how do you get to know
students in a really large class you
know like I think there is a cut-off
that I feel so the largest class I feel
is 55 where I can know students not just
know them but I know their lives beyond
you know like their their names I know
what their majors are what state they
are from or what country they're from so
certainly like getting feedback is the
way to know their lives beyond the
classroom right so like so I like you
know like in terms of so even during the
previous like beginning of the semester
when I have let's say a pre class
homework or something which I often have
to do have classroom time used for
conceptual questions and so on one of
the questions is like what do you like
to do or do you like the donut that I
brought to you the other day or you know
like like what are your interests but it
wouldn't like so those are the questions
that one can incorporate along with you
know like questions about physics that
you would ask and I think it's it builds
that trust I think it's certainly
incremental yeah thank you yep
yes when you get to know students as
well and you really understand their
life does it get harder to grade them
when they don't do well I mostly harder
I think it does in us and that's a very
good question I think one Sonne like you
know like like a good practice in
general is like blind grading as much as
possible without having without seeing
their names there could be some creeping
you know like like you like because if
you'd know the students you've read
their materials so you know their
writing and so on so if you're grading
this all the time then you cannot you
know like do that well all the time yeah
so like I think it's sometimes it I
think it's it's a it could be sometimes
hard to be completely fair but you know
one one does the best one can I guess
yeah I try not to have a historical
focus because you know like you know
like certainly there are handful of
people like who are women or people of
color who have contributed designs but
it is disproportionately you know like
that that like we just have to
acknowledge that in a sense but that
gives a false impression in some sense
that this these are the only people who
can do physics or math and so on so
certainly I bring examples whenever I
can of people who have you know like
like like for instance in math for
instance I bring sometimes Amy Noah or
something but but then like you know
like it's hard to exactly tell what is
the like you know like introductory
physics it's hard to make that relation
between symmetry and conservation laws
or something of that sort right so it
sometimes could be a stretch but but
yeah I think like whenever I get a
chance I would bring examples which are
not usually represented but the examples
that are overrepresented I try to just
not talk about it yeah
all right so I've I've had an
unbelievable experience over the past
three years and the partnership between
Yale and Housatonic has been incredible
and I have you know a story similar to a
lot of what you've heard so far but
right now I'm gonna zoom way in and talk
about one particular project and to do
that we're gonna play a video game sound
okay okay you don't have a choice so
this was a project that was helped with
funding from the Center for teaching and
learning
and as you just saw there there was a
there was a company we worked with to
help code the game and this this project
was joint with Yale math department and
in particular with Jim Rolfe we kind of
collaborated on this entire project but
I'm gonna start by just showing rather
than telling you guys so as you can see
it's not advanced graphics but what we
have is a game that's a two-player game
and the setup is similar to something
like battleship where as right now I'm
the red player and I'm gonna start
placing these targets so now I've
switched the blue player would go and
they place their target and like
battleship we're going to think that
eventually you're gonna try to hit your
opponent's targets so of course in
battleship you know you have some
strategy that you're going for and some
reason why you're doing the things
you're doing I'm probably not going to
do the best job right here but
ultimately I'm going to be trying to as
the blue player hit those red targets
and make it difficult for the red player
to hit the blue targets so maybe that
one will hide behind alright so once
we've created the set up the game has
begun and
each player is dealt a hand of cards and
these cards have simple functions on
them and the idea is I'm going to try to
create a curve that is hitting those
blue targets right now so I'll start
with a nice linear function each of the
cards has a slider with an Associated
parameter and so I'm not gonna belabor
this too much but once I'm happy with my
decision I'm gonna click that shoot
button
and we'll see so I've hit the blue
target that was good then I hit the red
one which was my own that was bad so it
stopped the curve and let's see I don't
have I don't have fun cards here so I'm
gonna click a redraw and I'm gonna go
back because there was some fun ones
there okay so now it's the blue player's
turn I'm gonna play it a sine curve and
so this is not so good at parameter I'm
gonna go with a cosine and what I'm
doing is creating these curves and
really just playing with what's possible
right there's not some motivating lesson
going on I'm just playing around with
what's happening and I don't know we can
get crazy here and we could start say
multiplying functions or even one thing
that students really struggle with is
thinking about this idea of composition
and what happens if you compose
functions so we had to think about how
do we get an interface that allows for a
composition and you can see you can
start to get some pretty wild things so
we'll shoot that that's pretty good all
right so there's your pre this this is
what we created and now I'm going to
tell you about a little bit about why we
created it how we used it with students
and where where we think it's going okay
so we call this game carts I don't know
I don't know I mean it comes from date
carts but I kind of like the name anyway
so I'm gonna zoom back out again we had
David Pursuit come and give a talk in
our STEM education series David persued
is in charge of this program
characteristics of successful programs
in college calculus through the MAA and
he's described what he calls the perfect
storm in college calculus which is that
greater numbers of students who are less
prepared are using sorry we're teaching
greater numbers of students who are less
prepared using fewer resources with
increased expectations of what's
possible and so this is the this is the
perfect storm those of us who teach
calculus have some sense of of the
what's going on and it is a big
challenge and in David's talk he put up
this one graphic that I found really
interesting and important and so
interesting important that I'm not going
to tell you what it says I want you guys
to think about what it says so we're
gonna do a think-pair-share
we're not going to talk for about 30
seconds or so you're gonna do your best
to read what's on the screen you don't
this isn't that important that's the
source I can tell you where it's coming
from but I want you to see if you can
determine what this graph says it took
me a while okay so now it's already
started naturally but you can do the
pairing so I'd like you to talk to your
neighbor about what you see this isn't
obvious and
so don't please don't be shy don't be
shy
see if this technique works okay good so
uh has anybody gotten any clarity on
what this study was saying yeah students
who have taken the college precalculus
the performance is less in getting good
grades in the college calculus compared
to the students who have not taken the
college precalculus right so if we if
we've gotten if somehow we're very ready
based on some score for calculus if we
go ahead and then take precalculus so
I'm gonna have to so this readiness is
entering college so this is before they
enter college if the student goes on to
take precalculus and then calculus good
preparation results in worse outcomes in
calculus that's weird that's weird but
there's also this other side of the
graph which says okay suppose some
student is underprepared and so this
readiness score is an amalgamation of
their grades in high school whether or
not they took AP courses SAT scores a
lot of things but it's some way of
comparing by the way this study was done
with 10,000 students so there's big
numbers but what's this side of the
graph saying I'll tell you it's saying
there's some inversion right calculus
precalculus should help but not really
right these are the exact same students
and what happened they took a semester
taking precalculus there's no
statistical difference in the outcome so
okay we could probably talk for the rest
of my time about that but let's just
leave it at this is concerning this is
concerning and and so the video game is
trying to address
these concerns right so how did the
video game come about we I came to Yale
and Jim Ralph was having conversations
with Lynn filin and Kimberly FJ I'm not
sure how to pronounce her last name I
should ask her but they have a center
for health and learning games and they
were creating games to help the
community understand health issues and
they found that through gaming they
could really make an impact on outcomes
and they said math is an open space we
think games are the way to provide
interventions and and you could you
could really do something here and so we
we work together as a department and we
we tried to determine what's a problem
we think we might be able to address and
a big problem for students entering
calculus is that they have weak
intuition for how when we think of a
function we can think of it as an
equation or we can think of it in terms
of a graph and they have weak intuition
for how to go back and forth between
those different worlds there's a big
problem and so what were we hoping to
change we're hoping to help students
just identify basic function types from
their graph and then have some idea that
if we have some parameter associated
with a function type what does that do
geometrically and then think about how
do we build functions up from these
basic types so the first thing we did we
ordered pizza and we invited students to
come and play the game at night they
essentially volunteered we sent an
invitation to a lot of students and we
had a lot of fun we had three nights
where they played the game they played
for about an hour it went really well we
were very excited Jim and I sort of
observed the students as they were
playing and you know they were talking
to each other and then we talked to them
afterwards they said they were making
patterns the things he want to hear
they said it was fun witnessing them
having fun so we were we were really
excited this was in the fall of 2016 and
so we went on and did another iteration
with the company that we were working
with and then we thought about can we
integrate this into a course that's
already happening which is a course
designed by John Hall which is targeted
at students entering with week
backgrounds and it's a year-long course
in which the precalculus ideas function
sense is built into the curriculum and
this course has weekly workshops as part
of the class that are led by
undergraduate learning assistants and so
we said we're gonna go hands-off we're
gonna give them this game and we're
gonna try to study the effects of how
students engage with it so they played
the single-player version they played a
multiplayer version we give some concept
tests before the game play and after and
then we had a survey and so what were we
trying to do we were trying to
understand some basic things the
students enjoyed playing the game and
what are the aspects of it that are fun
for them what should we focus on if if
we think that this is something that's
going to motivate them do they think
that they can help them learn what's
their perception of what's happening in
terms of the learning going on and then
can we actually affect learning so for
the rest of my time I'm just gonna focus
on do students think that this game can
help them learn right we tried to attack
this this question and the first thing
we saw was that they seemed to agree
that by playing with somebody else that
they were they were learning something
so the interaction was helpful to their
learning and when we asked them in what
ways did the game help you learn we got
some interesting responses in fact I
like focusing on the more negative kind
of snarky
responses because I think they tell you
more I do this in my own course
evaluations right it's tough but you
have to take it maybe with a grain of
salt so this student said while the game
didn't help me my partner helped me
which that's exactly what we wanted to
hear of course maybe that's not what
this student would have expected but
then we asked them whether or not they
agreed or disagreed with this statement
statement if I were to keep playing this
game what I do better in this course
okay so we asked them you know do you
agree or disagree so I'm just curious
here I want to get a thumbs up if you
think that a student would agree with
this and a thumbs down if you think a
student would disagree with us so what
you think for a second then I'll say got
my okay ready set go okay a lot of
thumbs up some thumbs down yeah yeah
they didn't think it was gonna happen
they didn't think it was gonna happen
and I saw John halls here he gave a
thumbs down so he has some insight into
the students psyche maybe this isn't a
surprise but but it's good to not right
we need we need to know this if we want
to use this and so what a student said I
ended up learning more by about
strategizing by clicking rather than
using my understanding of functions this
is a concern that they'd just mess
around and not really pay attention and
they said it's not really helpful for
this class okay next question a better
understanding of functions would give me
an advantage in this game so I want you
to think what would a student response
thumbs up for I agree thumbs down for I
disagree with us
okay ready set go okay now almost
uniformly thumbs up yeah they really
agreed if I just knew about functions
this would be better you know this I'd
be much better at this game and a
student said you know you should ensure
students have a better understanding of
functions beforehand
right I mean these are students in the
class where we're supposed I mean and
we're doing a good job where you know
this is this is working it's just it's
amazing to see how these students brains
are processing this stuff and again not
surprising when you know the students
but it's you know I don't know exactly
how to take this data but it's
definitely helpful as I'm thinking about
the game yeah so it's this comparison
that's very striking this disconnect
between you know how do you learn right
ok so just some reasons to be excited
about what we've done so far
the students are we've witnessed have
engaged in peer instruction they're
making predictions and getting immediate
feedback right you can see right away
what's happening and through doing that
they're recognizing patterns we know
this pattern recognition is really
important and they're creating some new
context through which they're thinking
about these functions but we have
reservations and the reservations are
that you know often students will resort
to guess and check
they said click rather than I'm thinking
about what's happening and I mean I
think this is a big one they they tend
to approach this with a fixed mindset
which is we know concerning and it's
interesting because I saw a game as a
vehicle where you might think of course
I get better you get better at any game
but but they they're perceiving it
especially at least within the context
we presented it as you know well you
know I'm not good at this and they're
not correlating the success between
what's happening in the game and what
could happen in the course so that's
that's what we've done and I'd love to
have your comments and questions
[Applause]
the game itself are the students played
on one computer laptop side by side and
they see everything yes right now it's
pretty low-tech and we just have them
yeah at a desk but actually right I see
that as an advantage right it's just
like you want to have them at the same
table you want to have them at the same
computer and often they'll they were
talking about they would strategize
together even though they were competing
or you know they learned something based
on what the other person was doing
because I keep getting that question I
mean our numbers are tiny there's not
yeah yeah so you can draw some
inferences you know there's it's way too
small
I'm concerned that the male respondents
were more excited about this than the
females yeah it's a concern and so we
want to make sure we're keeping track of
that yeah what we did talk so we talked
about this and you know having a
competitive game versus sort of
collaborative or just single player game
whether that might have some different
appeals yeah so Brett was the game only
available during class time or were they
able to put down their own computer take
it home they downloaded it they can they
can take it yeah it's a prototype and it
has problems and so yeah like my
computer tends to overheat when I run
the game for too long so it's very
limited we didn't want to put it out
widely but they those students that
played it do have it on their computer
we could check in if anybody's still
playing I think I talked to some
students that were in the initial focus
group and they showed it to other people
I don't know what happened out of the
class whether or not people continued
okay I want to thank everyone for being
here today and I want to just say a
couple of words before we go have a
lovely reception to celebrate the
accomplishments of these these wonderful
colleagues so as the PI of this whole
project as many of you know who have
written proposals for grant funded
projects this started with some
imagination and some data about
opportunities and needs and local parts
of the culture at Yale where I thought
there was fertile ground for partnership
and collaboration so I want to say a
couple of things that did a really
fantastic job with that long list of
people that we want to thank and I want
to say just a few things along those
lines first of all we have a really
great team here in the Center for
teaching and learning we have Jennifer
actually we have Glenn Davenport our
evaluator and we have Becca Roma and
Beth of course did not think herself so
I want to say a few things about Beth
that Beth and I have been working on
this project ever since it started and I
had funding to hire her and it really
was just words on a piece of paper so I
have to say thank you Beth for seeing my
vision and then I really just got out of
your way because you did a fantastic job
and something that didn't come out fully
in the presentations yet that Beth
really should take the credit for is
that she created a community among the
scholars they weren't just out in their
departments and off at their schools but
every week they came together and in
fact I think first Beth Beth thought it
would be every other week and they said
can we do this every week was that right
so the group came together weekly they
had each other to talk to about teaching
issues that they had each other to think
about troubleshooting they had each
other to talk about job searches and
what's next and of course they had that
supporting and guiding and mentoring
them all along the way so that was
something that there really was I think
an amazing outcome of what Beth created
for this this program so for that and so
much more thank you very much Beth
[Applause]
and I also want to thank our colleagues
in the physics and the math departments
here because they had to take a little
bit of a risk to accept these postdocs
and to include them in the culture and
let them loose teaching their students
so we couldn't have done the program
without these wonderful partners so
thank you also to our partner
departments and most importantly I think
our partner institutions a big part of
this program was and a big part of my
design was thinking that the the
postdocs experience learning to teach
and practicing their craft would be
strengthened by teaching in multiple
different types of institutions and I
think that's really been the case so we
couldn't have done it without strong
partnership from the University of
Bridgeport and Housatonic Community
College so thank you partners as well
and last and probably most importantly
thank Marko
Claudia Sivan and Brett when you started
and and for some of you I've known since
you were graduate students or maybe very
recent graduate students and now I think
of you all as colleagues so thank you
for your contributions to this program
it's been a pleasure to work with you
thank you all
[Applause]
[Music]
you